[MUSIC]
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER:
It is indeed a privilege, and also a genuine
joy, to address you, for all of you graduate
today having accomplished something that is
genuinely important and worth celebrating.
You have completed a demanding course of study.
It will transform your life in many ways.
It will expand the range of vocations you
can pursue, increase your knowledge of the
world, deepen your capacity to appreciate
societies and cultures, and provide a foundation
for lifelong learning.
As I look out at our extraordinary class of
undergraduate, masters, and doctoral degree
recipients, I take pride in your excellence
and your diversity, and I am excited about
the contributions you will make in the years
ahead.
The world needs more college degrees, not
fewer.
We need more celebrations like the one we
hold today, with more proud families and happy
graduates ready to go out and make a positive
difference in the world.
All of us on this platform are thrilled to
be a part of your celebration.
We applaud your achievements.
We send our best wishes as you begin the adventures
that lie ahead, and we look forward to welcoming
you back to this campus on future visits.
To all of our graduates,
congratulations and best wishes!
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]